- Hi!
Now, this is an amazing artist
named Bernie Houston!
- La galiériste Margery Goldberg
a, disons, un goût éclectique.
Son univers coloré tranche avec
le climat moroe e e la pandémie.
C'est devenu un lieu de
rencontre chaleureux sans
prétention, à Washington,
pour discuter arts et tableaux.
Dans chaque recoin de
la maison, une sculpture,
une peinture. Il n'y a aucun
espace vide. Et les affaires
vont bien depuis la COVID.
"Ça a été une très bonne année
pour la vente d'oeuvres d'art",
dit-elle.
"Toutes les galeries et musées
étaient fermés, dit-elle,
moi j'étais ouverte"
À la fois artiste et
galiériste, Margery Goldberg
est tout un personnage.
Elle a  fondé et tenu la
galerie Zénith en plein coeur
de Washington pendant 40 ans.
En 2011, elle la déménage
chez elle.
"J'ai mis le mari dehors",
dit-elle.
"Et ouvert la galerie chez moi,
et ça a marché encore mi
que je pensais."
À 72 ans, elle représente
une centaine d'artistes
du monde entier, dont trois
Canadiens, et connaît l'histoire
de chaque tableau.
"Un beau tableau, dit-elle,
c'est comme une relation
amoureuse, elle évolue avec
le temps."
"Margery met l'art au service
de tout le monde dit-elle,
elle soutient les artistes e
fait un travail remarquable." Me
aussi ses oeuvres. Elle sculpte
le bois depuis l'âge de dix ans,
ce qui lui a valu le surnom
de "la femme avec la scie".
Dans le jardin, la piscine
creusée est désormais le lieu
pour exposer les sculptures.
Il y en a pour tous les goûts.
Alors justement, comment
choisit-elle ses oeuvres?
Et le dernier qui a
déclenché une telle sensation,
c'est l'artiste Stephen HansenIs
connues, avec une touche
d'humour.
"J'aime beaucoup Hansen,onononz
nous, ses tableaux sont
amusants, et provoquent
toujours une discussion."
Et des discussions, il y en a
ici aussi. On parle de projets
futurs comme celui de créer
un centre d'art pour personnes
âgées.
Le rire de Margery résonne
dans toute la galerie,
un véritable répit pour
les artistes en ces temps
difficiles. L'art qui, une fois
de plus, est le parfait exutoire
en temps de pandémie.